[MUSIC PLAYING]
-Thank you, Judy, for that
very generous introduction.
And thanks to all
of you for coming.
Like everybody, I'm
especially appreciative
of the opportunities that being
at the Radcliffe Institute
offers for those of us who
just need an extended time away
from administrative duties,
in particular in teaching,
to work on a monograph
project like this.
So my aim today is to
offer a summary of one
of the chapters of my book.
But before I do that,
I want to give you
a little bit of background
on the book itself.
It's part of a trend
in the last 20 years
that has seen a real
explosion of interest
in the sea, prompted
in part by concerns
about the negative
impact of humans
on the marine environment.
The historical
ecology of the sea
has become a particularly
lively field, reflected
in new international
research initiatives,
such as Oceans Past and the
History of Marine Animal
Populations, that focus on human
responsibility for rising sea
levels and the depletion
of fish stocks.
For geographers and historians,
globalism and the unifying role
of oceans has stimulated
projects such as Seascapes
and Oceans Connect.
For archaeologists, research
on wetlands and coastal spaces
has boomed in the
last two decades,
evident in CITiZAN, a massive
UK network of volunteers,
to identify and
monitor important sites
around the coastline.
Maritime anthropology,
for long a leader
in framing humans'
relationships with the sea,
has responded to
this new interest--
I think is very interesting--
by focusing much more on policy
issues and on the
human dimensions
of environmental change.
Now, historians
have been interested
in all of these developments.
The rich interdisciplinary
perspectives
produced by this
new work, however,
rarely consider the Middle Ages.
And that's roughly the
thousand-year period
from around the fifth century,
the Fall of the Roman Empire,
to the 15th century,
the Renaissance,
exploration by sea-- expansion
of European exploration.
Now, I think that
this oversight is
due primarily to the paucity
of documentary sources
for such investigations.
I mean, medievalist simply lack
the personal correspondence
or the government commissions
or the captain's logs
and oral histories
upon which most
maritime and environmental
historians rely.
Now medievalists
are more fortunate
when it comes to the
work of archaeologists,
but even their
excavation material
has been employed largely for
understanding ship technology
and exchange by sea.
Another difficulty with
medievalists taking advantage
of this interest in the sea
is that although medievalists
have uncovered rich evidence
on how humans interacted
with and transformed
their natural environment,
the human-nature balance
was pretty different
than it is today.
Medieval people certainly
changed their physical world,
but nature, through such
events as sea storms and sea
surges, volcanic eruptions,
and epidemic disease,
was the chief protagonist of
medieval environmental change.
So my project, therefore,
focuses not only
on people as ecological
actors, but also-- and probably
to a greater extent-- on
how the maritime environment
itself influenced the people
who lived on its shores.
I'm especially
interested in analyzing
the impact of
marine environments
on the types of work, economic
strategies, value systems,
and family structures of
those residing near the sea
in medieval England.
And here, particularly,
the period
from the 12th through the
15th century, because that's
when both the documentary and
the medieval sources are best.
So this afternoon,
I want to focus
on how we can gender female
the maritime world of ships,
waterfronts, and coastal
communities-- a world
that scholars have
largely populated
with adult males--
focusing on four questions.
First of all, just saying, was
there a female presence at sea?
Two, what was the
experience of women
on shore, particularly in terms
of maritime-oriented work?
Three, what can a closer or
prosopographical examination
of one maritime community reveal
about women's status and family
strategies?
And last, how did the
marine environment
work through
demographic processes
to shape the role of women
and household dynamics?
So first of all, women at sea.
Now, medievalists have
really made almost no attempt
to gender female the maritime
world of medieval England
or even to explore women's
relationship to the sea.
And this is in
contrast to historians
of later periods, especially
the 17th century and later,
who have done absolutely
terrific work on this issue.
Even the recent survey by Susan
Rose, called, The Medieval Sea,
devotes one and
a half paragraphs
in the entire book to
women, alluding briefly
to the role of ship
owners and suppliers.
Nicholas Rogers' magisterial
The Safeguard of the Sea
does not even list women or
wives or widows in the index.
The two seminal works on
the medieval English Navy
by Nicholas and Laird both
restrict their coverage
of women to a short
paragraph-- they
use the same incident pointing
to a chronicler's assessment
of the failure of
a naval expedition,
as due in part to the presence
of prostitutes on board ship.
[LAUGHING]
Now, when the scarce
evidence is assembled
for the medieval period,
there are in fact
no signs that the sexual
geography of the maritime world
of medieval England
was any less divided
and dichotomous than early
modern and modern scholars have
found for their periods.
Indeed, the medieval world may
have been even more strictly
divided along gender lines.
With the exception of
some intriguing stories
about Viking women
sea raiders-- highly
suspect-- nowhere
are to be found
the female tars or the pirate
queens or women in disguise
as seamen that those writing
about the early modern world
have discovered.
And medieval women
just simply never
appear on board ship as
fishers, ship masters,
mariners, or even on
shore as shipwrights.
When English women in the
Middle Ages do go to sea,
it was mainly as
ship passengers,
although the
references are limited
to the voyages of
wealthy princesses
who go off to be married
or to female pilgrims--
sometimes, people
like Margery Kempe.
Women accounted for barely 3%
of the known English pilgrims
to Santiago in
northern Spain-- that
was really one of the
big pilgrimage sites--
a very small number,
even for a list focused
on those wealthy enough to
receive protections and safe
conducts for the journey.
Sea travel was dangerous
in the Middle Ages,
especially for women.
I mean, witness the tragic
fate of two female passengers
on a 14th century English ship
that was attacked by pirates.
They threw all the sailors
overboard, but kept the women
alive for three days so that
they could have sex with them,
and then threw them
overboard, as well.
So these are stories
that would put fear
into any woman's
heart who is thinking
about getting on a ship.
Medieval chroniclers
and sermon writers
also mention a few
prostitutes who
board ships, but their
numbers were minuscule
and their presence a device
to push a moralizing agenda.
Having "harlots" aboard
was to invite disaster,
if not a failed
expedition, then a storm
at sea, as several
exempla-- exempla are
kind of didactic stories that
are inserted into sermons--
as these exempla make clear.
In medieval England, prostitutes
were not, in fact, regularly
allowed on board
naval ships in the way
they were in the later
period, as this 16th century
painting shows.
Where prostitutes
were more prevalent--
and this is a good example of
similarities across centuries--
were in waterfront
areas, especially
in the large port towns.
So in a place like
medieval Sandwich, the town
itself established the
"common house" or the "stews",
which they called
the galley-- which
is pretty indicative
of the clientele
that they expected to come.
According to medieval
preachers, sailors' association
with prostitutes was seen
as one of their major vices
and linked with tavern visits
and profligate spending
of wages.
Now, although there
is, therefore,
little evidence of
women on board ships,
it is worth thinking more about
the contradictory impulses
evident in sailors'
superstitions
about women at sea,
compared to their tendency
to gender all ships female.
And this is grammatically
and largely in ship names.
And what are we to make of the
association of pagan goddesses
with controlling
the sun and stars
and protecting mariners at sea?
Which, in turn, may have
promoted the role of the Virgin
Mary as patron of mariners
caught in dangerous storms.
Then there's the
women in the sea,
such as sea nymphs who
frolicked in the ocean riding
on the backs of dolphins.
Or sirens, who are the
half-animal, half-human woman,
whose songs lured
sailors to their death.
Both date from the
Greek period, but were
firmly entrenched in
the medieval psyche,
as was the half-human, half-fish
mermaid, who tended to be
associated with vice and death.
By the way, they're
all associated
with very negative things.
All of these females of the
deep appear in medieval art
and in a wide variety of
secular and devotional texts,
and await the attention
of medieval scholars
interested in interpreting the
often conflicting evidence they
present about gendering
the maritime world
of the distant past.
It is not surprisingly
much easier
to find women ashore, working
at sea-related tasks for a wage
or profit.
It is important, however, to
distinguish between the work
profile of women in
larger port towns,
and what they did
in these smaller
coastal settlements that
were devoted more to fishing.
Women's work in
the seaport towns
was part of a very
occupationally diverse group
of people, and the
maritime work was dominated
by overseas trading interests.
And frankly, the work that women
did in these big seaport towns
was not that different
from the work
that they would do in
even a big inland town.
But there were a few exceptions,
and those are largely
ship-owning and overseas trade.
So Alice Chester of
Bristol was a widow
who continued her merchant
husband's business, regularly
trading with Iberia
and Flanders,
sometimes in partnership
with her son, John.
She invested her substantial
profits from these ventures
in property, constructing
new buildings,
loaning money, and
donating copiously
to religious and
charitable institutions.
She also built a
crane-- public-minded--
on Bristol Quay, for the
large sum of 41 pounds.
That is the equivalent
to the annual wages
of 10 labors over one year.
So this is really a
large amount of money.
Similar merchant widows can
be found in other port towns,
but like Alice Chester,
they were almost all widows
of wealthy merchants
who took advantage
of their dead husband's
business connections
and commercial capital
to continue the husband's
maritime trade.
They also represented a
really tiny percentage
of an already elite group.
Women, for example,
imported less than 1%
of over 5,500 incoming cargoes
at the southwestern port
of Exeter, from the late 13th
to the early 15th century,
and less than 1% of
all overseas imports
in late medieval Bristol.
Now, at the lower end
of the wage spectrum,
we do find women more closely
involved with maritime work.
In Southampton,
for example, there
was a female guild
of wool packers
who seemed to control
the packing of wool
to be loaded onto ships.
Their guild ordinances
in 1503 make
it clear their proximity
to quayside business,
as well as their
ability to elect
two wardens to govern themselves
from amongst their membership.
But guild vacancies
were to be filled
by the nomination of the
mayor and the corporation who
kept control of this guild.
And there's really
little trace of the guild
in later centuries--
in later decades even.
More common seems to
be these female vendors
of naval supplies for shipyards.
Naval accounts of the
construction and repair
of the king's ships record
a number of women selling
something called towe--
T-O-W-E-- or oakum.
And these are the rough
fibers of flax or hemp
which were used to caulk ships.
Several of these women had the
surname Flaxwife, a reflection
of the work that
women did, often
in the tedious and
very uncomfortable
process of separating
and processing
the fibers of flax and hemp to
make linen, wicks, and rope.
No women, however, ever appeared
amongst the ranks of the people
actually doing the caulking or
as shipwrights or as waterfront
porters, wine drawers, weighers,
crane operators, or custom
house officials that populated
the quays and the wharves
and storehouses of
medieval waterfronts.
The waterfront activity that
employed by far the largest
number of women was vittling,
particularly of ale and fish.
Now women brewed ale everywhere
in England, but in port towns
some of them did
operate on a larger
scale by selling wholesale
to departing ships,
particularly those
in naval service.
Such female wholesalers
were, however,
relatively few compared to
the number of male vendors,
and were often at the mercy
of the precarious payment
system of the English Navy,
which was always in arrears.
More numerous were female
sellers of fish, some of whom,
like Agnes Acrouch
of Winchelsea,
were wholesale
agents who supplied
substantial amounts of fish
to customers that included
large monastic households.
But most women who sold
fish in medieval England
did so at the lowest
level, as street hawkers
who worked for fishmongers
and other middlemen,
barely scraping out a living.
These fish sellers, like many
female hucksters of foodstuffs,
also acquired an
unsavory reputation.
So it's hard to know
where the term "fishwife"
acquired its negative
connotation of overly
aggressive rough
women who sold fish,
but as Isaac Land points out
for the later period, "Her life,
labor, and language, all marked
her as part of the maritime
world. "
Now, medieval women were
also strongly associated
with gutting, cleaning,
packing, and curing fish,
especially herring--
an association that
is found in most
fishing societies,
regardless of
location or period.
The most famous
medieval examples
are the women who gutted
herring and laid them
in brine at the seasonal
fishery of Scania, which
is in southern Sweden.
In its 14th century
heyday, this fishery
attracted 25,000 fishers,
merchants, vittlers,
and fish processors, from
late July to late September.
An account from 1494
indicates that about 175 women
were employed on a seasonal
basis there to gut and clean
the herring catch, as well
as some 100 alewives who
filled over 2000
barrels with ale
during the two-month season.
So these female migrants
were the predecessors
of the more well-known
Scottish women, most
young and unmarried, who
in the early 20th century,
moved steadily southwards,
following the herring as they
spawned down the Atlantic coast,
going from camp to camp to gut
and pack herring over the
course of seven months.
In the decade
before World War I,
about 12,000 Scottish
gutting quines
participated in this trade.
Now, there's no traces
in medieval England
of women working on this
type of massive scale
in fish-curing,
although there is plenty
of anecdotal references to
women helping to gut and clean
and cure fish, particularly
in the inshore household
industry, where wives
and daughters were really
essential to producing
a saleable product.
Herring spoils within two
days if you don't cure it.
So if you want a commercial
product, you need to cure it.
Now, the evidence
that I presented here
on the work of medieval
women in maritime communities
suggests that the maritime
environment offered women
several types of employment
that were generally not
available inland,
including high-status
ship-owning and overseas
trade, middling status
naval suppliers, and
organized wool packers,
and household-linked work making
and repairing nets, baiting
hooks, and gutting fish.
Three other forms of
employment-- prostitution,
fish selling, and brewing--
were strongly associated
with the sea, but were not
peculiar to the maritime world.
I mean, you could
find these women
in any town or
bigger settlement.
No women at all
seem to have worked
at sea as mariners or fishers.
Only the ship owners, the
merchants, and the wool packers
received profits that would
be commensurate with men
in these jobs.
But the female practitioners
of these trades
were a minuscule proportion
of the total numbers making
a living from this type of work.
And the fact that
the female ship
owners and overseas merchants
were widows building
on their husband's
businesses, and the tendency
for much of the work
done by maritime women
to be typically gendered
female and often of low status,
detracts from the independence
that such activities
might otherwise suggest.
Another approach that I
lean on heavily in my book
is called prosopography,
a methodological technique
that compensates for the
type of poor record survival
that we have for the
Medieval period by combining
all extant sources to create
a collective biography
of a particular social group.
Now, the method often draws
on quantitative analysis
to track patterns in things
like occupations, and office
holding, and wealth,
to uncover more
about poorly-represented
groups in the pre-modern past.
Now, prosopography
is labor intensive,
and it's not without
problems, chiefly, name
linkage across
different sources,
because the aliases
that medieval people use
or the different spellings
of their surnames.
And because in England,
I'm reading documents
in Latin and Anglo-Norman
and in Middle English.
So tracking these people through
even these different languages
and different documents
can be hard to do.
But this technique does
provide valuable insights
into the work regime, status
networks, and family strategies
in smaller communities,
like maritime communities,
given the right set of sources,
as I have here for Hythe.
Now, I do employ this technique
at several points in my book.
It's one of the reasons
I call it an ethnography,
because I'm substituting
prosopography
for the kind of
in-person fieldwork.
But in this chapter
on women and family,
my prosopographical analysis
focuses on the fishing port
of Hythe in Kent, which
had about 700 people
in the early 15th century.
Because there's a huge
array of rich sources,
as you can see here.
Now, the maletolt taxes
are particularly good,
and they show that about
21% of the households
were involved in
fishing in some way.
And that's actually a
quite large percentage.
And now there's two
tables that have
been handed out
because they're going
to be hard to see up here.
So especially revealing in
table one are the 205 wills
from before 1527.
Over 1/4 of these contain
maritime quests of high value
items, such as ships, vote
shares, and fishing cabins,
as well as fishing
gear-- so this
would be hooks, ropes, nets,
and other items associated
with seafaring or fishing.
An extraordinary large percent--
41% of these maritime bequests
went to women,
particularly widows.
Indeed, a percentage of sea
craft-related items bequeathed
to women in Hythe was
considerably higher
than bequests of
work-related equipment
to non-fishing families.
You know, smiths don't tend
to bequeath their smithy
to women in the family, or even
a forger or tongs or something
like that.
Also striking is the
contrast between the wills
of Hythe, this
small fishing port,
with those of the big seaport
of Bristol, where only 4%
of almost 300 medieval wills
contained maritime bequests.
And really, 1/3 of
these were simply
legacies to dockside
workers, not equipment.
The Bristol testators tended
to be well-off ship owners,
ship masters, and shipwrights,
more than fishermen,
like the testators of Hythe.
And with the exception of
ship owners, about 1/4 of whom
left shares in their ships
to widows and daughters,
the other maritime
occupations in Bristol
never left the tools of their
trade to their female kin.
And I've also added here the
ports of Lydd and Folkestone
to show you that it's not just
Hythe, but these neighboring
ports where you find a
similar type of profile.
And most of the women
in the Bristol ports
who inherited ship
and boat shares
co-owned their vessels with
sons or with their husbands'
partners, suggesting that these
maritime bequests were meant
to represent forms of
easily-liquified capital
for widows and dependents.
And really, at a
place like Hythe,
or at Lydd and
Folkestone, the frequency
with which fishing
equipment, in particular,
was bequeathed to all family
members, including women,
suggest inheritance
strategies that
emphasized a shared identity
and a common investment
in the maritime enterprise.
So the co-ownership
of such capital assets
as fishing captains, and boats,
and capstans, and windlasses,
and even nets, I
think also points
to the collective nature of
risk management in these fishing
communities.
Now, this is not to deny the
privileging of male heirs,
which you're going to
see right away looking
at table two-- especially sons.
A hefty percentage of the widows
receiving maritime bequests,
for instance, were
guardians of minor sons.
And when older sons were around,
widows' share of these bequests
did tend to be lower.
Male kin were also
favored over female kin.
Male servants and
fishing partners
could be beneficiaries,
although sustaining the family
enterprise seems to
have been paramount.
A number of the
wills, for example,
make clear that
whoever of several sons
pursued fishing was to get
the testator's boat or nets
and hooks.
Others gave first crack
at buying these implements
to their brothers.
And although it's impossible
to value the bequest because we
don't have inventories,
my impression
is that, by far, men got the
higher value fishing gear
than the women.
The most frequent
maritime bequests
were nets, which accounted
for just under 1/2
of all the legacies, compared to
25% for boats and boat shares.
As I said, sons were the single
largest beneficiaries of nets,
but really daughters
were not that far behind.
After that, came hooks,
which were the most commonly
bequeathed items to daughters.
And you have to think about
this-- they were not going out
to fish, and yet they were
receiving these bequests.
So the relative
frequency with which
women were receiving
these types of bequests,
and even on occasion
bequeathing them in turn,
reinforces other evidence
that women's maritime labor
within fishing household
was oriented, in large part,
towards making and
repairing nets and baiting
hooks for longline fishing.
Both tasks could be done
on shore, close to home,
and required skills, such
as spinning and twisting
fibers, threading and knitting,
that were usually associated
with women's household work.
Women were also involved
in the growing, processing,
and spinning of hemp
and flax, material
used in ropes and fishing lines.
In other words,
this maritime work
reflected typical gender
divisions of labor.
I also want to argue
that this type of work
brought women into-- firmly--
into the maritime sphere.
So in his will, John Tiedemann
of Folkestone, for example,
ordered that his wife
should be allowed
to dry the nets that he had
left to her outside the fishing
cabin that he'd actually
bequeathed to his son,
implying his woman supervised or
shared in a fishing enterprise
separate from the son.
It's unlikely that Tiedemann's
wife ever went to sea,
but she was the
stakeholder or an investor
who owned and looked after
capital equipment, such as nets
and hooks, and thus, was due a
share of the fishing profits.
And we can see other
evidence of joint enterprises
like this in a lot
of references that I
had to take out of the paper in
order to meet the time limit.
So on to the fourth
and last question,
and that concerns how the
marine environment worked
to shape demographic forces.
These would be things
like mortality, migration,
marriage-- in
maritime communities.
Now, this demographic
question has
been addressed by early
modern and late modern--
there's quite a few
articles on this--
but no medievalist has
ever tried to take this on,
because we don't have the data.
I mean, demography tends
to be highly quantitative.
You need numbers.
So you need parish
registered data
about when people were
born and when they died
and when they got married.
And we don't have that.
So what I have done, and what
most people in my position,
is we look around
for what we can get.
And we often take observable
phenomena in the later period.
And so I have six separate
demographic characteristics
that I've identified in
later maritime communities.
And we look for traces
of those things.
We look for hints--
little bits and pieces.
So that's what I'm
going to do now
is quickly run through
this list of six things
to make some
suggestions about what
I think are real parallels
between the demographic
situation in medieval English
communities and later ones,
anywhere from the 17th
to the 19th century.
So the first of these is the
regular and often long male
absences from home, due to the
demands of fishing expeditions,
naval ventures,
privateering, and piracy,
or coastal and overseas
trading voyages.
Now, I stress here,
these absences
were highly seasonal,
affected not only
by weather-- I mean, the Baltic
just shut down in the winter,
for example.
Nobody was going to Scandinavia
in January and February.
As noted here, also, there was
an abundant-- largely anecdotal
evidence, however-- that
medieval fishers and seafarers
were often away from home.
And they didn't hesitate to
migrate to other regions,
as well.
And these absences actually grew
longer in the later Middle Ages
because English and
French and Iberian fishing
all started to expand
to Greenland and Iceland
and further north
in Scandinavia.
And so, of course, they're
away for months at a time.
In England, they
went first to Ireland
before they went anywhere else.
And then you also have
the Hundred Years' War
during this period,
which means a lot of men
are away on naval ventures.
Second is very high
male mortality.
The risks of
drowning in shipwreck
are apparent to anyone who
reads the long list of victims
in the eyre rolls,
which recorded
these problems in detail.
Some losses were so
dramatic that they
were noted by chroniclers, as
when a sudden gale destroyed
25 English ships and all
their crew on their way
to Iceland in 1419.
The naval service required of
so many mariners and fishers
also took its toll, in deaths
at the hands of the enemy
or pirates in long captivities,
and at-large ransoms that
took months, if not
years, to collect.
The small fishing port
of Budleigh in East Devon
complained, in 1347, that
in effect, continual service
to the Crown had cost its
residents three ships, 12
boats, and 141 men.
And even today, I
might add, fishing
has the highest mortality rate
of any occupation in the UK.
Three, the seasonal work
regime of fishers and mariners
that I've been talking about
affected the seasonality
of marriages and births.
In the early modern
fishing ports
of Brighton and Lowestoft,
for example, marriages
peaked in the winter after
the fleets returned home
from two to three months
fishing in the Yarmouth herring
fisheries.
So basically, nine months to
10 months later, lots of babies
were born.
And I could show you the graph.
I mean, it just goes up
like that all of a sudden.
Very few conceptions
or marriages
occurred in the fall months
when the fishers were away.
These seasonal patterns could
vary by maritime occupation,
however, since sailors
on trading voyages
were more likely away in
the spring and summer.
And the type of
maritime activity
pursued by male
householders thus shaped
the timing of the births in
the settlements, and their work
regime, was affected
by the seasons
of when they could catch
fish, most of the time-- when
they could go to sea.
Now, we have no firm
quantitative data
for this process
in the Middle Ages.
But we do know-- and I have
numbers for tens of thousands
of fishers who were at the
Yarmouth and the Scarborough
fishing-- they call them
fishing fares, F-A-R-E-S--
and they were away for two
to three months of time,
in a very similar
seasonal pattern.
And they probably
had a similar pattern
of conceptions and births.
Fourth are low sex
ratios, and that
is more women than men in
maritime communities, which
was a result of the frequency
of these male absences
and the high male mortality.
Maritime scholars have argued
that the surplus of women,
combined with the
authority that women
had to assume when their men
were away for long periods,
in the essential role
that fisher's wives played
in baiting hooks, and mending
nets, and curing and selling
the catch, endowed
maritime women
with more agency and
influence than they would have
had in land-based societies.
And I'll come back to that.
Five is that young
seafarers tended
to marry at a younger age
than landward counterparts.
And six, that seafarers,
especially fishers,
had endogamous marriages.
That is, fishers married the
daughters of other fishers.
Now, this practice may
have been encouraged
by the co-ownership of boats and
the ease with which young men
could start fishing
and make money
to support a family, especially
when the fisheries were
booming.
Age at marriage in a
pre-industrial society
is determined-- to
a large extent--
is about when you can
afford to get married.
And if you're involved in an
industry where you can quickly
make a lot of money, you can
afford to get married earlier.
And especially fishing
families, they simply
could not survive without wives.
They're very much
like farming families.
A study of the early
modern fishing community
of Lowestoft in
Suffolk found that 40%
of seafarers' marriages
were to other fishers.
That's an enormous
percent, really,
suggesting that this pattern
of endogamous marriage
may have stretched back
across previous centuries.
Now interestingly, fishers
married earlier than mariners,
perhaps because wives were
so essential to the success
of the family
fishing enterprise.
Different types of
fishing enterprises
seem also to have wielded
different influences.
So this deep-sea
fishing for things
like cod, where you're
going to-- initially you're
going to Iceland and
Greenland and Ireland,
and then you go to
Newfoundland-- they
had less incentive to keep
boats and tackle in the family
because these guys were
heavily paid by wages.
And so it may be that
their marriages were
less endogamous and
maybe less early
for these types of reasons.
There's also some
quantitative evidence,
yay-- we don't have much,
but when you have it,
you have to make the
most of it-- that
can be employed to reinforce
the hypothesis that medieval
and later maritime
communities had
similar demographic regimes.
It comes from one
of the more-- well,
it was the most robust
tax return, actually,
from medieval England, and
it's called the 1377 Poll Tax,
because they taxed every single
person over the age of 14.
And that's quite remarkable
for a medieval tax.
And we have their
names, and they're often
grouped by
households, so we know
who's living in the household
and who's part of the family.
Now, we don't have
returns for everywhere.
And unfortunately, for the
places that I'm looking for,
which are these rural
maritime communities,
there's only a set of three,
which is in Lincolnshire.
But anyway, and it's
called Skirbeck.
It has three bills.
But I was able to compare
it with a very large sample
of inland villages, and it
provides some suggestive data.
For example, two measures
point to the possibilities
of high male
mortality or absences.
The quite low sex ratio, column
two, for the three Lincolnshire
villages-- 94.7 compared to 100.
The 100 would be equal men
and equal numbers of women.
So 94 means you have
substantially more women
in that community.
And the high percentage
of households
that were headed by
women, column four,
over 21%, which compares
to only 18% to 14%
for the inland villages.
The relatively high
percentage of single people--
that's column three--
in maritime communities
could also be interpreted as
a reflection of male absences,
especially given
the low sex ratios.
The fourth measure, the
high mean household size
in the Lincolnshire
maritime villages,
could be construed as an
indication of early marriage
because it would lead
to larger families.
But it could also
be a reflection
of the considerable prosperity
of this particular region
of Lincolnshire, since we know
that richer regions, richer
households, married
earlier and had
more children than poorer ones.
So the jury's still out on that.
Now, medievalists
don't really have
the firm solid
demographic data enjoyed
by scholars of later
materials, but I
think that this type of
material I've presented here
offers suggestive
parallels of continuities.
The medieval evidence
for male absences
and high male
mortality is anecdotal,
but frequent and regular,
while the surplus
of women in medieval
maritime communities
can be seen in the poll
tax data on low sex ratios,
the high percentages
of single people,
and the large numbers of
households headed by women.
And then if we add to this
this will evidence that I have
from Hythe and some of
these other places that
reinforces studies of later
centuries, that have outlined
how male absences
and high mortality
may have increased
female autonomy
and fostered very specific
types of inheritance strategies
that kept assets, especially
fishing tackle, in the family.
There's less evidence of
early and endogamous marriage
in the medieval
records, although I
think there's some
possibility with surname
studies of pre-14th
century material
that could prove fruitful.
Certainly, further analysis
of the wills will be helpful.
The Kentish fisher, Adrian
Dynes, for instance,
only bequeathed cash legacies
of six shillings eight pence--
a couple months'
wages for a laborer,
not very much-- to
each of his daughters
if they married a landsman.
But if they married
fishermen, they
were to get a sprat net,
which was likely worth more
than the cash legacy.
Several other
fishermens' wills also
mention the fishing equipment
that came with their wives
into marriage, either from a
first marriage to a fisherman
or from a fisherman father.
So I think that this
type of evidence,
as I'm starting to
accumulate more and more,
really offers these quite
interesting parallels
to the firmer evidence we
have for later periods.
So in conclusion, what I've
tried to do here is quickly
bring together a wide
amount of scattered evidence
to show how the marine
environment influenced
the role of women,
their work, and family,
in maritime communities in one
location-- in medieval England,
and particularly, in the
12th to the 15th centuries.
I've argued that prevailing
gender norms prevented
the participation of
women in work at sea
and limited their work
options, even on shore,
to those traditionally taken
up by women, which were often
linked to household work,
such as ale brewing, vittling,
and working with hemp and flax.
Some women were able to take
on more remunerative work
as vendors, selling
naval supplies
or even trading overseas,
although, the higher
profile that these few
women enjoyed usually
came by virtue of
their position as wives
or widows of prominent men.
The situation was different
in the smaller maritime
communities, especially
fishing villages, where
the work of female
householders in mending nets,
baiting hooks, and curing
and selling the catch,
was really crucial to the
survival of the household
economy.
The maritime work
that women did,
as well as their inheritance
of fishing equipment, also
show how fishers' wives
and daughters could
be drawn into the
male maritime world
that we are familiar with
more than their landwards'
counterparts, who did
not enjoy the same access
to these work-related bequests.
Unfortunately, what
the sources don't tell
us is how much maritime work
was really socially valued.
I mean, you can
make all the guesses
you want about its
economic value,
but we just don't
have declarations
or any type of
evidence to say we
know that that economic
value was there.
But how much was
it socially valued?
And I think one of the
problems with people
who declare how important,
economically, women's work was
in the fishing industry, is
that they never compare it
to the work of farming families,
where women's work, wives'
work, was just as essential.
There are not a lot
of unmarried farmers,
just as there's not a
lot of unmarried fishers,
because that
household economy is
so dependent on wives and other
women within the household.
And that's the next
step is to do more overt
comparisons there.
There were, however,
several aspects
of the marine
environment that may well
have augmented female agency.
Despite the strong
sexual division
of labor in medieval
maritime work,
the relegation of
women to specific tasks
does not seem to
have resulted always
in the feminization of work
that was associated with women.
And I think this is particularly
the case with fish curing,
although I can show
you lots of pictures
of women in fish curing.
It never loses prestige.
You have men doing fish
curing all the time,
and if you know anything about
the Newfoundland fisheries,
men completely controlled fish
curing for centuries there.
That part of it
was not low status.
Another example is how the
marine environment shaped
the seasonal demands of
fishing and seafaring,
and thus, men's frequent
absences and high mortality
which, in turn, left many
women to manage the household.
Now, coping on one's
own is a mixed blessing.
But in Paul Thompson's
words, it quote,
"gave women a practical
basis for power."
This autonomy could
be legally sanctioned
as it was in medieval Barcelona,
where seamen's wives enjoyed
unusual legal and
inheritance rights
that helped families cope
with the long absences
and early mortality of
fathers and husbands.
Now, written laws to
this effect are not
found in medieval England.
I've looked.
But customary practices, such
as the inheritance strategies
evident among the fishing
families in medieval Kent,
provide suggestive
evidence about how
dependence on
marine resources may
have occurred the development
of different types of family
dynamics.
And finally, let me say
a few words about how
the coastal ecosystem may have
encouraged shoreside family
members to identify
with the norms
and practices of the maritime
culture of seagoing men.
Residents of
shoreside communities
were very familiar with
the wrath of the sea,
particularly, the storms and
the destructive flooding that
could wash away
whole settlements,
as a series of early
14th century storms
did to the Yorkshire
settlement of Ravenser
and to the low-lying
pastures of Sussex
or the Suffolk town of Dunwich.
These places are just
under the sea now.
Flanders has the same problem.
To combat these dangers,
maritime communities
formed collaborative enterprises
to maintain seawalls and dikes,
or cooperatives to reclaim
low-lying lands from the sea.
And they also developed
customary laws,
such as the Statutes
of Romney Marsh,
to adjudicate problems and
assess financial responsibility
for the repair of sea
walls, since one breach
could destroy hundreds and
even thousands of acres
of a family's livelihood.
Now, women did not serve as
jurors in the Romney courts,
but they did appear as
litigants and landowners
with a stake in upholding
this collaborative system.
Similarly, women did not
play the same active role
as men in such
maritime enterprises
as smuggling and wrecking.
Wrecking is the salvage
of goods washed up
on shore, which in
maritime communities,
may have actually been
hastened by, let's say,
false beacons and lights
and things like that.
And it was profitable.
But the women colluded
and facilitated
the disposal of goods
acquired through these means.
They're often named as receivers
of stolen or wrecked goods.
Although the women
and a fair number
of men in coastal communities
never worked at sea,
many of them lived
from the sea, in that
they or their households
labored in ancillary shoreside
occupations.
Their reliance on the
sea for a living, or even
coastal residents' proximity
to, [INAUDIBLE] action
with what we call the maritime
cultural landscape-- of beaches
and dunes, fishing
cabins, beacons,
and boats, a very specific
kind of maritime landscape--
meant that they
probably absorbed
many of the same
superstitions and traditions
of their seagoing relatives,
participating, for example,
in the annual
blessing of the nets
or the yearly breakfast that
was hosted by signorial lords,
such as the Lord of Otterden, at
the end of the fishing season.
It's also likely that
the distinctive shoreside
activities undertaken to
support maritime households,
such as working the salt
pans or mending nets, gutting
and curing fish, collecting the
harvest of inshore seawares,
and shellfish beds, and
retailing the catch,
all helped to deepen the
investment of all family
members in the maritime
enterprise-- and, I think,
extended identification
with the norms
and practices of the
maritime subculture
to those who stayed ashore.
So I think by broadening
the scope of the inquiry
here to assess how the sea
shaped the lives of those who
lived on its shore,
we can now argue,
find a place for women in the
family in medieval maritime
history.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]